um hi good evening
my name is alan gerber i'm the director
of the institution for social and policy
studies
and dean of social sciences at the yale
faculty of arts and sciences
welcome to tonight's event on the 25th
amendment
a constitutional mechanism for removing
the american
president uh this event is one of a
series
of webinars that isps is offering
uh it we're gonna have we've had a
couple already
on the election we're going to have some
more in coming months
as part of a program called isps
democracy isps democracy is aimed
at supporting research and discussion to
further
understanding and improving democratic
representation
and accountability these conversations
and the research that we do
um is of course of great academic
interest
and but part of what brings us together
today
is that we can see how some of the
work we do uh collectively thinking and
writing about
um about the problems uh and issues in
american democracy
can can in in a in the after a series of
of years uh turn into the
foundations for and the tools we have
for um for navigating political crises
so
um so this work that sort of starts in
the academy
um can actually uh become an important
part of
of the the the real um
the real essence of of how we um how we
engage
governance together um tonight uh
we have a number of distinguished
scholars of constitutional law
and american politics uh to talk about
um the 25th amendment to the
constitution
and this spring we'll have a number of
other events
as part of the isps democracy program
and i'll just want to tell you about
about those very briefly
um these are tentatively scheduled for
february 9th
we'll be having a webinar on the new
administration
what's next for governance and
legislation
on february the 23rd a webinar
on rethinking political representation
novel ideas for candidate recruitment
voter education
deliberation and policy making
march the 16th we'll be having a webinar
politics in a transformed communications
environment
and then later this spring um i'll be
uh working with a number of scholars
across the university
um on a on an idea of that we're still
um still kind of putting together um
but it's to think about policy making
and government performance during covet
19
as a vehicle for exploring both the
specific policy failures
but also general lessons about democracy
and policy making in democracy so those
are some of the things we'll be doing
as part of isps democracy
in the coming months before i i proceed
i do want to thank
the organizers of tonight's event this
was
put together rapidly in response to
uh to national events um the organizers
are pam greene
uh pam lamonica tori bilsky and
lamourpeer
and um these uh these amazing
individuals are
responsible both for the organization of
tonight's event
um as well as um they were also
responsible for prior events and they'll
be
assisting in the upcoming events and
without their work none of this
could really be put together let me just
give you
finally a little bit about the format
for tonight
um each of the panelists will be
speaking for seven
to ten minutes and then after that we're
going to
request an answer period please send
questions throughout the session using
the
q a button at the bottom of the zoom
screen
good questions there are usable
questions or questions that are about
one sentence long
or maybe two sentences long so so try
and um there there are definitely fora
where very long questions are welcome
and brilliance
and helpful but i i think we've found
that in this setting it's the short
questions that are
that are somehow sometimes most uh most
helpful
so please write short questions and then
if you need technical assistance along
the way
uh please email isps yale.edu
and then finally i just want to tell
everyone that this event is being
um being recorded so with that i just
would like to introduce tonight's
panelists
i'm going to introduce all three and
then they're just going to talk in order
they're going to appear in alphabetical
order first akila mar
professor amar is sterling professor of
law and political science at yale
university
and one of the nation's leading scholars
of constitutional law
his work has been cited by supreme court
justices from across
the spectrum in more than 40 cases he
regularly testifies before congress
is a member of the american academy of
arts and sciences
and a recipient of the american bar
association's outstanding scholar award
he's a graduate of yale college and yale
law school
and the author of dozens of law review
articles
a number of books as well including the
constitution today
timeless lessons for the issues of our
era
he has written on the 25th amendment uh
creative ideas for how to use the 25th
amendment
and he has an op-ed in today's uh
today's i think new york daily news
um addressing the current political
situation
uh in using the 25th amendment and
how the 25th amendment might be used uh
in response to the current political uh
political challenges
our second panelist is john ferrick
uh professor ferrick is a distinguished
scholar and academic leader
the norris professor of law and former
dean of the fordham university law
school
where he served as dean for for about
two decades
he specializes in constitutional law and
theory
employment labor and arbitration uh
in 19 2006 fordham university
established
the ferric center for social justice at
boredom law school
the center's mission is to protect the
underprivileged from a wide array of
social ills while working to bolster
workers rights and access to legal
services
as editor-in-chief of the fordham law
review he wrote an article about
presidential succession
which served as a as one of the
foundations for
uh the 25th amendment uh to the
constitution
which was an amendment that that he uh
he helped to craft
uh craft into the form that we see in
our constitution today
so i i will say i have never um had the
privilege i think of
of interacting with somebody who helped
to author
part of our constitution and so i just i
couldn't be more
more pleased and honored that um that
professor ferrick is here with us this
evening
and then third we have uh david mayu
a sterling professor of political
science emeritus
uh david is a fellow of the american
academy of arts and sciences
the american philosophical society and
the national academy of sciences
he is one of the nation's leading
scholars in american political history
u.s legislative behavior political
parties and policy making
he is a resident fellow of the
institution for social and policy
studies
and the author of many landmark works
including congress the electoral
connection
and divided we govern he has an
encyclopedic knowledge
of american political history and
um and it is again a real honor to have
him with us this evening to
share his insights um with that i just
want to turn it over to akil
then john and david thank you all very
much
well thank you alan it's such an honor
to be with um
such an extraordinary panel um i'm going
to try to
actually be brief because i want to hear
um from
the great uh john furrier and the great
david mayhew i have to be especially
modest because
john furrier you're here to talk about
the 25th amendment he not only
basically wrote the 25th amendment he
wrote the book
on the 25th amendment called the 25th
amendment
so wow um and and as alan said
there's no one who knows more about
congress who is living now and maybe
who has ever lived than the great david
mayhew
the 25th amendment and such an honor to
be with you both
really you guys are my role models in
life um and
um the 25th amendment has several
provisions
i think it was put it was briefly put up
on the screen let me just mention
a couple of them uh and and try to
show you a larger structure um let me
start with
something that john furrier i think told
uh wrote
long ago that before the 25th amendment
we had
no mechanism for filling a vice
presidential vacancy and for 40 out of
the first 160 years
the vice presidency was basically empty
at some point
either because the vice president had
died or resigned actually john c calhoun
you know who's been recently renamed
hopper um uh resigned
uh for a brief period um or um
uh so 40 years in which either the vice
president was dead or
a resign and therefore there was a
vacancy or the president
had um died um um and the vice president
had moved
up william henry harrison you know
zachary taylor
abraham lincoln james garfield
mckinley and and so on warren harding
so the president had died and the vice
president
moved up to fill the presidency and
there wasn't a mechanism for filling
that vice presidential vacancy for 40
years
there's this emptiness section 1 of the
25th amendment says here's how we fill
it um
the president basically nominates
someone to fill that spot
and then there's a congressional
confirmation process that's a little bit
more elaborate
than the ordinary cabinet one that
involves the house as well as
the senate that's how when uh spiro
agnes
and and all of this let me take a step
back
is after the assassination of president
canada
when lyndon johnson becomes president
and the vice presidency remains vacant
so one problem is do you really want to
have a a a vice presidential vacancy
which requires then if anything happens
a statutory succession
and the statutes currently provide to
the speaker of the house
um as next in line and i'm not sure that
makes sense and i'm not sure that makes
sense given the 25th amendment so i'm
going to actually again try to show you
some of the implications
of this so um uh
kennedy is killed um johnson becomes
present there's no way of filling that
vice presidential vacancy
john ferrick writes you know a piece
about that the senate gets involved the
house they adopt this amendment
um and the first thing that they say is
gee when there's a vice presidential
vacancy the president can fill the slot
that's section one
and so when spiro agner resigns because
he was a crook
um uh nixon picks
ford um under the 25th amendment section
one
and ford's confirmed eventually um and
then when nixon resigns ford looks
moves up and under the 25th amendment he
picks nelson rockefeller
now here's one thing if you think deeply
about the logic of that
you vote for republicans you should get
republicans for four years
you get nixon if not nixon agnew there's
not agnew ford if not
ford rockefeller kind of apostolic
succession
but boy that's the logic of section one
the current succession act is weird
because you vote for
um uh um trump and uh trump pence and
you could end up with pelosi
you vote for obama and you can you know
end up with paul ryan you vote for
reagan um and you end up with tip
o'neill
um now my friends that's deeply
destabilizing in fact
put it mildly it's an assassination
incentive if you can simultaneously
knock out present and vice president you
could accomplish regime change
if you do it serious oh um you knock out
one person someone else moves up and
then they pick a successor in its
apostolic succession
but somehow both of them went at once
imagine a bomb or something like that
now party control lurches to the folks
who lost that presidential election
is that the right approach the 25th
amendment says the
vice president should be basically um
occupied by someone
who works hand in glove with the present
the president hand-picked
um beginning in the 20th century really
presidents hand-picked
their running age that wasn't true
before but by the middle of the 20th
century that's basically
uh true um uh ike threw the the
nomination um open to the convention in
56 with the father but usually
presidents picked there they're number
twos batman and robin
they they can work closely together but
that's not true for you see the speaker
of the house necessarily so
so section one has implications for
statutory succession
um there are other provisions of the
amendment one
that says oh when the president just
voluntarily
needs to step aside for a moment he's
going to undergo a colonoscopy or
something else that's going to put him
out for a while he can voluntarily hand
over power to the vice president and
that's what i wrote about today
maybe trump can do that today he can he
doesn't have to resign
and to step aside and and and put pence
in charge
as you know as if you were undergoing a
colonoscopy for
for eight days for ten days he needs a
rest uh
so but that works best when there's a
teamwork between
president vice president they they
basically are
mates they're they're running mates um
and but that doesn't work again
with the speaker of the house who might
be someone different the political party
section four which you've heard a lot
about is
an involuntary transfer of power not
triggered by the president
but when the vice president thinks that
the president
is disabled in some way mentally or
physically remember
this is triggered by kennedy's
assassination the vice president
with the approval of the cabinet or some
other body can displace the present but
what if the present
challenges that there's some provisions
of all of that so
so the 25th amendment has several
different provisions
in it we need to understand how it fits
together has all sorts of interesting
implications
beyond um just the the one right now
could
tense displace trump could trump step
aside um
and and other implications too i've said
enough for now i want to get of course
john and david in
and then i'm sure we'll have a lot of
back and forth but if you have
any real questions about the the the
amendment that we don't cover today
this is the bible that's john furrier's
book and you're about to hear from john
pierce because he
wrote the amendment i want to thank you
very much uh uh
we just added in terms of the book that
uh its value is uh
reflected in the uh barnes and noble and
other bookstores is ten dollars
uh because it was reprinted by uh
by uh barnes and nobles uh uh to make it
more available
but uh to the subject uh i'd
i'd like to start with one i want to say
it's an honor to be part of this program
tonight with you akiel and and professor
mayhew and uh
and to be at a yale law school as well
uh a great great law school uh
uh i start with the original succession
provision uh which is
the an article uh uh two of the
constitution
and uh and and and my sentences of it is
as follows
that it deals with the contingency of
death
resignation removal and inability
of a president and also a vice president
uh
it's ambiguous as to uh as to
uh what happens in the case of death
resignation removal and inability
it just says the same shell de bob on
the vice president
so leaves open the question of the
status
and the succession contingency uh
there's no definition of inability uh
there's nothing in in the original uh
constitution as to
how you go about judging uh the
existence of a
of a presidential inability and the
second major
uh provision of article uh
two of the constitution is it gives
congress the power to establish
a line of succession and we've had three
lines of succession
in our history and initially
we had the two leaders of congress in
the line of succession
starting with the president pro-tem and
then the speaker in 1886 the line of
succession
went to the cabinet departments and then
in 1947
the line of succession uh started with
legislative leaders in a reverse order
speaker and then the president pro tem
in the line of uh and the cabinet line
and that's the existing
line of succession now uh
when the first uh president died william
harrison
an issue arose as to the status of the
vice president john tyler
and he claimed that under the succession
provision when you read the succession
provision
he said in the case of death uh in the
case of death
the president had died i become the
president i get the title of the
president and i serve for the rest of
the term
some members of congress at the time
said no no no
uh and john quincy adams said that in
his diary no no no
you're an acting president uh uh
and and you haven't but tyler made it
stick
and that became the precedent uh in in
the future
when presidents died in office they
followed the tyler president i
become the president for the rest of the
term of the existing president
however that created a a further
ambiguity because uh in in
1881 when uh president garfield was
shot and eventually died uh 80 days
after being
shot uh he uh it was not clear uh how to
deal with a case of inability
because inability was it was in the same
clause
as uh death and some said well
if if the vice president becomes uh
takes over the uh powers and duties he
becomes the president
regardless of whether the president
recovers from uh the
the apparent inability at that point uh
in in terms of those 80 days
and so there was and then it was not
clear
uh who who could j who could make the
determination of that ability chester
arthur
uh the vice president he wasn't
interested in getting involved in making
the determination
he came from a different wing of the
party and uh and even the assassin
uh uh implicated uh
that wing of the party so to speak so uh
so that was it became a dead provision
it was not clear who made the judgment
and also what the status was and now we
move in to
jump ahead to the eisenhower he is he
had three uh
at least three presidential abilities
and a heart attack and a stroke he had
an a a internal issue
and uh and he wasn't able uh for
a week or more than a week uh uh uh in
that time period
and he was anxious uh through his
attorney general a graduate of yale law
school herbert brownell
a former editor-in-chief of the lawyer
view
review
we got to deal with this
constitutionally
and they they launched the hearings
at the time and the house was very
active through its uh
chair of the judiciary committee
emmanuel seller of new york
but they couldn't really come to come to
agreement on
how to deal with this subject where
president's disabled
uh and we'll figure it out when it
happened so to speak
uh it was the result of all that well
eisenhower
uh was was used to command right
uh and in terms of his military history
and outstanding military history
and he said well i'm going to work out a
protocol with my vice president uh
richard nixon and i and i'm sure herbert
grenell and
and his successor were very much
involved in that
those ideas and that is to say we're
going to develop what we think the
constitution means
and what we think the constitution means
and we're going to put it in a letter
a letter between the the president and
the vice president
and uh and and that letter in them and i
think
roughly march of 1958 said
that uh if if the uh
and this is eisenhower's uh idea that
the uh
uh that that if uh i wanna declare my
disability because i
gonna have an operation as professor
morris said for colonoscopy the next day
and i'm to be unconscious during part of
that operation i'm going to pass over
my powers and duties uh to you uh mr
vice president nixon you take over as
the acting um
president and i'll tell you when i'm
ready to come back again so that's sort
of the first
protocol they worked out in this letter
and and then the second protocol had to
do with a situation where
if i it says eisenhower if i'm unable to
uh
uh determine my inability i want you to
have the power to declare you have the
power to
say that and but to have some
consultation before you exercise the
power
and that that's this that's the second
uh strand of
of that uh letter and the third strand
was
uh and then in any event whether it's
the first strand of the second stand as
soon as i said i'm ready to take it over
i i get it back and that letter
agreement then flows into the kennedy
years
between uh president kennedy and lyndon
johnson and when president kennedy is
assassinated
and and linda johnson becomes the
president
he works out the same agreement with the
speaker of the house of representatives
because he's the next in line of
succession we don't have a vice
president
because we have no procedure fulfilling
a vacancy and a vice presidency
and at the time that that happened so
what happens if the president was
disabled
you would see in the newspapers at the
time and and suppose kennedy didn't die
and and and he lingered between life and
death as
as as garfield did how would we deal
with that
uh we would have had that uh the
protocols of the eisenhower
administration but
some would say well that's not law
that's just an understanding between the
president the vice president we're
talking about the constitution
here so at that point senator birch bai
of indiana
uh inherits uh all the ideas that were
around during the eisenhower years
inherits the work of the senate
judiciary committee and the house
judiciary committee with the different
proposals and different ideas
and he comes up with a a framework
that's not
too far away from the uh the letter
agreement
uh and and as you as professor moore has
said
uh the framework is president can
declare his own disability under the
uh the 25th amendment and as soon as
he's ready to come back
he comes back there can't be any check
on the section three about him coming
back
and in terms of section four which is
has a lot of detail
in it uh section four uh says well the
vice president
and uh not to consult but and uh
majority of the cabinet heads of the
executive department's
commonly uh referred to as the cabinet
but there might be others who sit in the
cabinet who are not in that group
roughly i think there are 15 department
heads today so
you need a you need uh the votes of
eight eight eight
department heads and sometimes it might
be an acting department head because
bartman head has has left and and and
somebody has had to step
up some people will create is create an
issue as to whether
that person can vote i think they can uh
but
uh and and then uh uh
suppose the president doesn't accept the
declaration of inability what happens
then
well uh uh once he says uh uh i'm i'm
i'm able i don't agree with you vice
president and
and cabinet i i think i'm ready to uh uh
i i'm okay
i'm not where you think i am and uh
and uh and and and and they then have to
uh evaluate what the president has said
uh
they have four days to do so under the
25th amendment and if they disagree with
the president
it's first it's going to go over to
congress but when they
make the original determination the vice
president immediately takes over as the
acting
president and uh with all the powers
duties of the presidency the president
doesn't lose
the presidency he's just taken over the
discharge of the powers of the
presidency
and that's what and uh and and he's
going to hold on to that
uh the vice president because it's been
a question of capacity that's been
raised and
and rather than have it back go back and
forth
he's going to stay in the process of the
acting president until it plays itself
out
and if there is a disagreement it goes
to congress
and it takes a two-thirds vote of each
council of congress to say
uh whatever it's going to say which
effectively means if the president
secures the vote of one-third plus one
of either house
at that point he resumes his powers and
duties and the house
has uh the senate has 21 days
or both houses have 21 days to take the
process and if they do nothing at the
end of 21 days the president
resumes his powers and duties but as
they say as soon as one house plus
uh once say uh we agree with the
president he immediately resumes his
powers and duties
so and but keep in mind uh under the
25th
amendment uh after uh eight days from
now
uh it's uh it's moved because uh
uh uh uh the president's term is over
and and the and the acting president uh
president
current uh vice president no longer is
an office
and it doesn't pass to the it doesn't
pass to his successor because
the president uh the president that
he was acting for has has left office so
so eight days from now whatever it is uh
25th amendment is uh is moved uh the one
uh
uh the one thing it uh it does is
during those eight wet days the powers
and duties are with the
uh the vice president so that uh if
they're going to be any pardons
uh uh the president doesn't have the
pardon empowered that all of that is
with the vice president
because he's taken over all of all the
powers of
of of the presidency and if there's a if
if it's if the vice president cabinet uh
believe there's a risk
of to the security of the nation because
of threats in the world
uh uh the person who has control of it
during that
period is the acting president so uh
that that sort of uh gets you into the
25th amendment and it went through
congress with
support by democrats and republicans in
both houses of congress
and and and they worked together and all
the detail that you see in there
uh and and it was uh it went
the aba played a very major role in the
knowledge in the legislative history
and and my involvement was through the
american bar association asked me to be
on the committee of 12
uh that was given this opportunity so to
speak to
make recommendations uh we worked very
closely with
senator uh birch bai and and and and
those in congress and
and it was in the constitution in
february of 1967 i may have run out of
my my seven minutes but
let me just end by saying
that uh i wrote a tribute to uh and akil
has a wonderful tribute as well in this
issue of the fordham lawyer view uh
uh concerning the uh the role of uh
senator birch bai
and uh and i end up my own uh uh
tribute which is in an article of
fordham lawyer view i i say the
25th amendment in the words of its uh
the principal author of
birch barn that's that's the article in
november of
uh recent recent november and and kyomar
has an article in the very full article
i might say and what i say there is
michael mansfield of montana was the
majority leader at that time
and he was a great majority leader in my
uh my opinion
and when the when the first uh uh step
was taken and the senate had
approved a draft of the 25th amendment
would still
undergo change in
i think it was december of 1964 he
complimented senator buy it but he also
said uh uh this will set
well in uh
in this building in the building we call
the republic
and i kept thinking about that when i
saw that building uh
uh ransacked uh last wednesday
and uh so um
that's that's sort of my my my opening i
i look forward to uh participating with
the others and answering questions
thank you
um yes thanks for inviting me i want to
say
i know virtually nothing about the 25th
amendment
and they brought me here for a
background about the
american history in particular and i
said i would take a stab at it
but let me think about a general
category
which is elected executives leaving
office
for whatever reason before their terms
running
whatever reason that's fairly common
in presidential systems that is this is
surprising
about latin american presidencies of
which there are a lot
and the term that's used for this is
interruptions
that is for whatever reason the
president doesn't finish a term it can
be for
for impeachment and conviction can be
just resignation
mobs in the streets that's fairly common
coups that's not so common in latin
american anymore but anyway
it's possible to get rid of presidents
in presidential systems
now the u.s this country has had only
one such
interruption since 1789
1788 only one and that was nixon
nixon went out of office before the end
of his term
in august of 74 he was not impeached
and he was not convicted but he would
have been both those things
if he hadn't got on his plane that's an
interruption
that's only one instance it almost
happened with andrew johnson in 1868
a vote short an impeachment and almost a
senate
conviction otherwise
in recent times since watergate in the
1970s
half a century ago impeachment by the
house
has until this week anyway becomes
something like
an expression of extreme disapproval for
a president
without much expectation expectation of
the senate marching along
it's a way of saying we think this guy
should go
but not we don't expect that he will
it's something like a accenture vote
and the congress can do that also in the
uh
famously andrew jackson was censured
formally censured by the senate that
made a mark it took a few years now
for that to run out of the stream of
politics in the 1830s
joe mccarthy was sent that they thought
as president was
actually uh literally condemned but
centered as everybody says by the
by the by the you by the
1954 why has the u.s had one only
only one interruption thus defined
in nearly a quarter of a millennium
it's not very many well one reason i
think is this that is
alexander hamilton was very smart about
this
as about almost everything else and
argued
that you've got to be careful to set up
a set up a process that won't get
weaponized
by parties or politicians or factions
making it easy to throw out presidents
and they will get thrown out
it's like putting matches in front of
six-year-old children to allow a process
to
get rid of a president easily and it's
not good for a system to have to be able
to have that happen
and why has the the whole business of at
least impeachment
become more common in recent times as
the last 50 years
well i maybe it's the example of
watergate
it's a kind of path dependency
maybe it's that maybe it's just the
country's more polized
maybe the presidency is stronger than it
was and therefore the stakes are higher
all those things are possible in any way
there are very few
data points but still between 1868 and
1974 a full century
it was nothing now let me get onto that
impeachment on to the process
of removal authority in the 25th
amendment
it says the president if they could go
out if the president is
president is unable to discharge the
powers
and the duties of the office the
president is unable to discharge the
powers and duties of the office
what does that mean it can mean almost
anything
you could find 500 psychologists to
declare that almost any president is is
crazy
you could do that you want to watch out
for weaponization the kids with the
uh manchester amendment the 25th was a
product of the
1960s but i would like fred i'd like to
play a
founder a counterfactual game briefly
and run it back
through american history and speculate
about what might have happened if this
had been on the books from the start
the 25th amendment it would have been an
alternative process for getting rid of
presidents off
after all now uh
phys physical disability was the obvious
reason for the amendment and i think
probably the most important and
interesting possible usage
in history would have been regarding
woodrow wilson so after all was
embedded and largely disabled for a full
year and a half
at the end of his second term and if
this amendment had been on the books
it's possible at least
that his cabinet or some selected
congressional body would have reached to
get rid of him
it's possible we don't know there's a
lot of allegiance to him
but that there's your best case it's
changed before removal
and uh over those of those many many
many decades
otherwise well they're they're either
farther countersexuals
we've been lucky the country has that's
very
so few presidents have become disabled
like wilson some of them were this
you could imagine counter factor you
take take fdr
from medicine say coolidge roosevelt
linda johnson if they had gotten elected
to another term
there's a very good very good chance
that they would become disabled or died
during that term of severe heart failure
in all cases
that didn't happen now beyond the
health disability there's a possibility
it's a possibility of
is there a possibility of weaponization
of the 25th amendment if you look back
with
think of some instances that way i mean
there in other political systems
cabinets
do take out their leaders after all
in parliamentary systems that's kind of
an obvious thing but
but uh margaret thatcher kavanagh killed
her off
or even take the um the soviet union um
kruschev was
was killed off by it would amount to a
cabinet that said that only killed let
me just put over office
by those folks it's difficult to imagine
in the american system the cabinet doing
that
after all the president selects the
cabinet their allegiance to the legion
to the president so
it's right now is that it possible to a
measurement
to imagine it it's been put up in the
last week after all the pence could
combine with the cabinet
to put together a statement that would
lead to
trump's removal it's not out of the
question it's uh
i think but kevin it's very difficult
back in the beginning of american
history there are some instances where
cabinets were at real odds with their
presidents
maybe there are three instances where
presidents inherited
their cabinet members from a previous
president
john adams did that and uh john
tyler did that and andrew johnson did
that and it's possible
that uh that
games could have been played somehow
either they're too erratic or they drink
too much or something like that
to combine with the political reasons to
take them out that's possible but it
didn't happen
and notice it's not just the cabinet who
can take out it's
any other such body any such body chosen
by congress can move
under the 25th amendment it seems to me
that allows
a larger opening for weaponization
the congress to some other body it's uh
it's it's not it's that easy to see
whether it could have happened in
american history that
could have happened but i do think if
the counterfactual
the best counterfactual that comes to
mind is this suppose that um
roosevelt had had died in 1943
rather than in 1945.
that would have made henry wallace the
left winger the president of the usa
at the end of the war and going into
1946
and he was thought to be somewhat spacey
in the head among other things so there
were gurus and so forth connected with
and it's quite conceivable
that seems to be that the congress
somebody could have put together a case
combined with a political animation to
take the guy out
that's possible you have to think
thinking about
weaponization now and generally in
general it's not going to turn the
presidency into a turnstile
and i know that but but still
but thank you thank you all very much
for um
for those remarks let me just start with
a a question to the group
and then um uh if you have questions for
each other we can go to those and then
um and then we can we have a number of
questions from from the audience
so um and this is again an optional
question so i didn't
so you don't have to this is not a
situation where you'd have to answer any
questions or anything like that
um so let me just ask you a very pointed
question which is
you know do you think that given the
current political situation
it is in a it is we have appropriate
conditions
uh for the use of the 25th amendment by
by the cabinet and uh and vice president
pence
um and uh and then um on balance
um do you think it's a good idea uh
to use the 25th amendment um uh
in this manner or for an adverse removal
of the
of the president given the precedent it
sets
and again i don't want to prejudge
whether that would be a good or a bad
precedent it set it down but it does set
a precedent
and i i think that um as as
professor professor mayu as comments
indicated
once we started using impeachment um
we've now started using impeachment
quite a bit more
and so um so these initial acts
using constitutional mechanisms they
rarely
remain confined uh to a one and one only
use
of the of the constitutional provision
so um so maybe we can um go in
in alphabetical order again and and if
you have comments you'd like to make
so the key to the 25th amendment
section of four
which is involuntary removal
is that nothing that the pivot is the
vice president united states
he's the one one soon enough she
who will become a acting president
um if section 4 operates and unless
she steps forward affirmatively
nothing can happen so she has to
basically say
i think the president is out of it
and remember she's generally hand picked
by the present
um either because they ran together and
in the modern world their running mates
and
and presidential nominees picked their
running mates
um or um she's been actually hand-picked
under the 25th amendment itself under
section i think i misspoke before
section
2 of the 25th amendment if there's a
vice presidential vacancy
the president has picked her to fill
that slot so
she's hand-picked why because this is
the turnstile
problem um we we don't want palace coups
so
lightly so so the person who's going to
actually have to
lead the charge is the vice president
united states
not chuck schumer or nancy pelosi or
anyone
on capitol hill it's the vice president
that's first point
and the vice president is going to need
to get the approval of
somebody now the body unless congress by
law specifies otherwise is the cabinet
who's the cabinet those are hand-picked
people by the president the one who the
vice president is seeking
to displace typically they they're
picked by the president
the senate has confirmed them but
hand-picked by the president they're
removable at
will by the present so these are the
president's people
and so this is designed to guard against
palace coups against promiscuous use of
this because it's the presence
hand-picked running mate who's leading
the charge backed by a majority of the
prez's
hand-picked cabin now i'm going to say
one other thing this is a fraught thing
because if the vice president tries to
do this and doesn't pick up the vote and
the president gets wind of this
oh my goodness that that could be a
rather chaotic situation
and what happens if the president starts
to hear about this and tries to
fire peep cabinet officers very quickly
so that they can't side with the vice
president so so section four and and
it's not as if john burke and his
colleagues didn't think about all those
things
he absolutely did and he tells the story
um of uh in his his writings on
on all of that i myself this morning
urged a different thing they said oh it
went to be so much nicer if
trump himself just used section three
um he can do that himself he likes
making decisions oh he's deciding
no one's pushing he can come back at any
time
that he wants unlike section four where
it once the process
begins um uh the vice president is gonna
be in charge and he can't just
automatically the president can't just
jump back in
so you know now it's not going to happen
probably but
section 3 is a different mechanism in
which the president can
voluntarily step aside voluntarily step
back in at any point don't expect it to
happen but that's a different mechanism
then section four which in the current
situation
um is a complex one because pence
doesn't want to do it
the cabinet scared uh some of them of
trump and
and he may fight back and um so
section four in this nanosecond has some
complexities truth be told
good um john and david do you would like
to comment on this
let me just uh just a few uh comments uh
because i know that students and others
in the audience will have questions
uh on on the question of uh
of interruption uh i i would point out
that the
eight times in american history before
we got to the 25th amendment uh
presidents died in office and and there
was
many cases of vice presidents dying in
office so there's a
substantial period of time
where there was uh one might say
uh interruption but the uh succession
statute being there
and uh uh that interruption uh uh
didn't quite uh lead to
uh kind of instability
uh our succession system worked
and i would also uh point out that the
25th amendment has been in fact for 50
years
hard to believe i've lived that long but
uh
and and we haven't seen that any uh any
any
misuse of uh section four the amendment
quite the contrary
uh presidential administrations i don't
know about the current administrations
have worked out detailed plans to
to deal with those succession
contingencies that might occur and a
number of those uh
plans are on file at fordham law school
in a
a presidential uh succession uh file
that
that we develop uh henry wallace uh
uh i find that uh reference to henry
wallace and roosevelt interesting
because
i discovered that in my file
when i sent my original reprint of that
article in 1963 around
i sent a copy to henry wallace and i
have a letter from henry wallace
acknowledging
with gratitude uh my and uh
my uh uh represent and saying i never
thought about disability during
roosevelt yes so uh i found i said
that's a historic document i never knew
i i had that
so i'm happy to share it with uh uh uh
professor mayu uh and what else uh
um i i can probably pick up the other
points uh
um uh uh the other uh question was
definition you said that you
you you used the word uh correctly so uh
unable
uh in in the amendment senator birch
buyer on the
senate floor in uh uh 19
in february of 1965 said
when we say unable we're talking about
inability
and we want that to be understood as
the legislative intent and uh
and and that's in the record in june 30
1965
just before six or seven days before i
went to the states for ratification
there's a long uh uh colloquy between
senator robert kennedy and and senator
bert spy
concerning what they intend uh to be
covered by the 25th amendment and
obviously
situations of physical mental illness
are
are are dealt with eisenhower would say
if if a president's plane went down and
you couldn't reach a president that
would be an application of section four
or if a president was
kidnapped that would be a a an example
of uh
a section for use or it would debate
when uh uh
that took place during the watergate
years when uh nixton was uh
uh on the rocks was uh would it be
appropriate for him to take
uh the 25th amendment section three the
one that
professor omar spoke about i i i did an
op-ed at the request of the times on
that subject and others wrote on the
subject and i think the thinking was
that
circumstances and conditions were such
to
uh uh impede impair
prevent the president from uh
discharging uh his powers and duties and
there was a need for the public business
to have an acting president
that would be covered by a section
section
well covered by the inability provisions
so presumably
uh the example i gave you was sex
section three
and and and the amendment doesn't
doesn't uh uh
get into a definition uh other than you
the legislative history that i mentioned
just like the original constitution
didn't so and just like the succession
law doesn't uh
do so because there are so many
different circumstances that might occur
and and you want to have a certain
flexibility there but what the 25th
amendment does
it sets up a process and as a professor
moss says
who does it who does he give the power
to it gives the power to the vice
president
and a majority of the cabinet people
presumably loyal to the president
haven't been involved and been selected
so to speak by that by the president and
of course the president would have had a
lot of input in
who's the vice president so uh it was
felt that
if we're going to get into that area of
uh possibly destabilizing
the country as might some might observe
uh we want to be sure that those aligned
with the president
are re are taking responsibility for
that decision so all of that is in the
25th amendment
yes uh three points first alan's
question
would the 25th be a justifiable use
of uh right now i think the answer is
yes
it might not be practical because there
are only eight days to go
but on the on on the merits under the
law
well yes and it's a plausible
construction at least could be made to
sound like a plausible construction of
unable to discharge the powers and
duties of his office
he's going kind of berserk anyway who's
listening to it
to you or you can't discharge the duties
if you're out there officials have gone
away
so i think it's possible it's point
number one point two and these are
disjointed one is that
actually my instance of entering wallace
was wrong was that let's think a thing
to a kill
he was a vice president at all i didn't
realize from reading it
that the body uh set up by congress
would have to be triggered by the vp i
guess that's quite right
he's critical yeah so he was unlikely to
trigger his overview well i have to take
that one back
it'd have to be impeachment of that case
and i think it might have happened
actually in 25
or 46 but that's another matter but some
vice presidents have been
at odds with their presidents in a deep
way
they have and and um
and uh for example in john adams's
territory it would have to be jefferson
who took a
move to the wolf to take him out
cooperation with a high federalist from
new england there's an odd coalition for
you
not inconceivable although quite
unlikely put it that way
um the third point i'm listening to a
keel about how it's a good point about
how if the president gets wins
that his cabinet is getting frisky
toward him why then
then the president might take action and
then you know get rid of his cabinet
actually trump's getting rid of us some
of his people there who have been giving
up trouble or
just throwing over the side in the last
two weeks ago
getting rid of them and all in one said
something of the spirit of
sultan says murdering all their siblings
need me in order to consolidate power
something like that you just take them
all out at once
but that could be done but they've
nonetheless with the american cabinet
system the way it operates at least
since the 1860s
it's really not very likely that the
25th is going to be used in some
in some um some some some weaponizing
fashion i could see a big used it
will throw both circumstances good
okay so we have a lot of questions and
i'm gonna
start just like almost literally reading
them word for word
um some of them are are really like very
short answer questions about technical
aspects
of the application of the 25th amendment
so let's
um if possible let's get through the
questions we
we need to keep our answers as brief as
possible
um and some of them are a little more
theoretical so it's going to be hard but
we'll do the best you should please do
the best you can okay
um uh here's one isn't the turn to the
25th amendment today a symptom of
congressional weakness
and a distraction from impeachment the
obvious constitutional remedy
any anyone want to comment on the on the
relative on that issue impeachment
versus
25th amendment impeachment requires
wrongdoing the 25th doesn't you know you
could you could have actually
been the victim of an assassination that
only left you deranged for example and
not dead so
so um 25th amendment doesn't require
wrongdoing
and in theory it should be a little bit
quicker
because it pivots on one person the vice
president and the small group
the cabinet at least initially
impeachment's going to be
half of the house of representatives
eventually two-thirds of the senate
after a full-blown trial with due
process
oral arguments lawyers cross-examine oh
my goodness
so those are different scenarios yeah
and and maybe setting the precedent for
a rapid impeachment
might be a you know might be insane if
the facts are not in dispute but if the
facts are in dispute do we really want
precipitous action that way that comes
in general isn't
that well set up for precipitous action
devices one person
can as a pivot person can actually in a
smaller
cabinet that's a body that's designed
for speed
good okay thank you can i put a footnote
on that of course of course john
the footnote would be uh under the 20
under the impeachment
process the president's removed from
office and and then there can be a
separate vote to disqualify him from
holding any future office
uh presidents never loses his office
under the 25th amendment he loses the
discharge of the powers and duties of
the office whenever the vice president
takes over as the acting president he
remains president
his title is intact that's not so in
terms of the end of the impeachment
process
thank you john just to follow up there
was another question which said
basically
suppose um suppose the congress sustains
the removal of the president
if it comes to pass that the president
um recovers
uh his or her powers of
to discharge the office do they can they
go back and and say now i'm ready to
return
uh to office uh uh yes the is the answer
and senator bai uh and i think i make uh
a reference to it and
and i quote senator bye in this recent
article i did
uh uh uh you can it can be uh
reactivated the process uh however uh
assessment might be made of whether or
not you're dealing with an abuse of
office
and that might subject uh uh president
to uh the impeachment process
good thank you okay um here's another
question given the counter factuals
raised by
professor mayu in actual political
development since the passage of the
amendment
what are the shortcomings of the
amendment as written
uh for the 21st century one area
uh that uh it needs to be dealt with is
if
if there's a disability of the president
and the vice president at the same time
or if you have one or the other and
and for example you have a a a
vacancy in the vice presidency and the
president's disabled
how do we deal with that i think vice
presidential disability more generally
vice presidential vacancy um and
the succession act i think needs to be
changed it shouldn't be the speaker the
house
should be some of the other party
speakers the house actually often don't
know
what's happening in the world truth be
told um
they tend to be people who are in the
middle of their parties which is at the
25 yard lines
rather than closer to the middle um
and um and they can be of the opposite
party so
if president of vice president go slowly
at siri autumn
and they're replaced nixon for agnew
ford
rockefeller but if they all you know die
at once god forbid in a terrorist
incident or
a covet epidemic or something like that
you have an effective political
assassination you have
power shifting to the party that lost
the presidential election
that's not a good system so i think we
should now and
and who should be next in line you could
make it a cabinet officer again
hand-picked by the president secretary
of state defense commerce
treasury attorney general or you know if
you're an american league fan you could
create a designated hitter you could
have a special
office um the vice vice president third
in line
you know i'm in the line of succession
but out of the line of fire
um today if you were creating that you
know for the democrats it would probably
be
barack obama and for the republicans
it'd probably be george w
bush because let me tell you as someone
who's getting close to you know i'm i'm
seeing the end
of life myself and worrying about my
retirement plans and all the rest
something simultaneously happens to
president the vice president the markets
go down
40 around the world and and by the way
other bad things happen when markets go
down 40 around the world
all sorts of hell breaks loose and one
person that i'd want in that situation
is someone who knows how to do the job
because they've already done the job
you know who has all the world leaders
on speed dial
and who knows the protocols and
procedures and even the codes and that
would be
obama for the dems and w i'm not trump
uh when he seemed to be ex but w for the
republicans so but that would be
creating a special office designated the
vice vice president
okay if i could just add to that of
course uh
if you if if you don't if you have a
vacancy in the vice presidency
uh the inability provisions uh uh aren't
workable
requires a vice president if everything
pivots on the vice president and if it's
that
that's empty i think you could
interpolate that's the next in line who
can kind of act in loco
vp but that's you know an interpolation
yeah and a lot of proposals came from uh
presidential succession uh
a clinic i think at both yale as well as
florida law school
um a question uh for professor mayu
and again this is a very big question
but um briefly
what are the historical precedents for
the national crisis we are seeing now
well that's a tough one something like
watergate in some ways that is some bad
stuff going on at the capitol induced by
the president
which everybody sees tells us everybody
seems to be bad stuff that's one
um that's first that comes to mind
i mean if you take it just in terms of
um attacking the capital
or the capital danger is the war of 1812
also during the civil war
in 1861 the capital was in great danger
for a while but lincoln took over the
presidency it's a matter of luck
that the confederates couldn't come in
and transition
uh those things those come immediately
to mine
david i would add that andrew johnson is
impeached
for his um um wild
uh rhetorical attacks on congress itself
you know we swing around the circle in
1866 and all sorts of things
congress which has the power of
impeachment tends not to like it when
presidents go a little too far in
attacking congress itself just
you know it seems to me good
i thank you very much okay uh here's a
technical question about
a majority of the cabinet assuming
congress doesn't designate a different
body
um does that include how do you how do
you count votes like what's the
denominator
in that and and and what's the new
basically what's the denominator and
what's the numerator
and to determine a majority of the
cabinet do we do we know in the
in the the constant in the legislative
history or is there some constitutional
understanding about that question john
furrier
says that the numerator and denominator
includes acting cabinet officers he says
that in the book it says that in the
legislative history in a certain report
at page three
that i could cite to you um and he says
that in his most recent
op-ed in the new york daily news and so
i i hope he doesn't contradict me on
this because
you know it's you'll also find that in a
a committee report as well
dealing with the uh moving down the line
in terms of the next
whoever has charge of the powers and
duties in the department of the
uh like the last week we had some
secretaries who
resigned but there are acting
secretaries who
would have the voting power even if they
weren't confirmed
which is unfortunate that they would not
be confirmed but that
in terms of the a disability unlike
the succession statute that requires uh
the cabinet to have been
confirmed by congress otherwise you
don't qualify in a line of succession
thank you um there are some questions
about um
the the 14th amendment and
um and i guess that's uh insurrection
insurrection and rebellion
um the section three uh provisions
um as a i guess an alternative
foundation for
um for uh considering removal of
of of the current president um what
what's your sense of that
either in general or in particular at
both i guess
um a lot of actually people in congress
have reached out to me about that i've
been in conversation with
10 different scholars about that
truthfully don't read don't pay
attention to a bunch of op-eds on this
there's a lot of sloppy thinking on that
let's just
um not focus on that right now
truthfully i think it's it's mistaken in
a variety of ways that it won't hold up
under long-term analysis uh other
other thoughts um on that
okay no uh let's see
okay um
sorry moving up the list uh
okay given where we are on january 11
2021 um do you think
uh do you think that invoking the 25th
amendment now would have some
important impacts you mentioned for
example that
donald j trump could no longer give
pardons
what other reasons might there be why
this might be something important to do
or do you know if you think it's
important what are some of the reasons
why you might think it's important to do
well i i i store uh a reference in the
and uh of citizens making reference to
the use of presidential power in terms
of
uh using our military might and that
might affect uh
relationships with countries and other
parts of the world
that the new new president will have to
deal with uh
if if if if it was an exercise of power
and areas like that that could uh raise
questions about uh uh whether it was an
appropriate use of the power because of
what's going on right now
which might be a reason that some say uh
calls for the use of the 25th amendment
so the full powers of the president
are under the 25th amendment are being
relocated
to the vice president so that's so and
it i won't speak about this present but
if you imagine
that you actually had a president whom
there was a real question mental
confidence
you want that person's finger on the
button that's
what americans were focusing on in the
wake of
hiroshima and nagasaki when jack kennedy
is killed
and in a way we're lucky truth leads us
i hate even saying it myself but but we
were lucky that he was killed and not
merely deranged
because if he was deranged in a nuclear
world and he doesn't recognize his own
mental inability so there has to be a
mechanism in the 25th amendment prize
one
for someone competent to come in if he's
not all there in a nuclear world and
that's
partly what john um meant when he talked
about the the military
um now it's not just that mike pence and
that the president would lose the power
to
give pardons if he handed over power
voluntarily under section three
or was um relieved of command under
section four
think of the kane mutiny or something
like that when the
the captain is relieved of command okay
so he can't give hearts anymore but
here's a little interesting wrinkle
truth be told
if i'm trying to sweet talk to trump
into taking this thing because i wish he
would
step down because i'll be able to sleep
better for the next week
whoa when you step down you can't give
pardons anymore but you could never have
pardoned yourself anyway that would have
been improper well but you can get a
pardon now because someone else is
president
so you at least have the possibility of
that now don't you
um um and if there were a deal or
pre-arrangement that would itself be
impeachable perhaps but you remember
ford pardons nixon
in theory if the 25th amendment were
activated
pence would be making pardon decisions
for all sorts of people including the
trumps
um just saying okay
um uh david do you have anything you'd
like to add
to this okay good
um are there futures
are there few are there actions future
presidential administrations
can or should take to ameliorate the
gaps or ambiguities we currently see
in the succession process short of
supporting
constitutional amendments so what are
there a couple key things that we might
want to do
i guess from a statutory standpoint
yeah the succession act is a is
dangerous it's an accident waiting to
happen
anyone who for example was a fan of the
west wing tv series
it makes no sense at all there was a
vacant vice presidency
um so martin sheen had to step aside
temporarily and you end
you voted for a liberal democrat from um
new england
and you ended up with john goodman who's
this you know conservative republican
that makes no sense and then jed
bartlett
spoiler alert comes back you know to the
presidency eight days later and
meanwhile
john goodman's had to give up his
speakership um
his seat in the house of representatives
for eight days it's it's a completely
bonker system and we got to change it
before someone gets hurt
and that requires a statute a new
statute and the continuity and
government commission
agrees with me about all this this is
post 9 11.
i've had a lot of distinguished people
on it was brookings on one side and aei
on the other included a past speakers of
the house including
newt gingrich and they agree with me
that this is a really
a dangerous statute that needs to be
modified
thank you i would add three things uh
further clarification on the issue of
acting secretaries i think uh
that that should be expressed a little
bit more
in the presidential succession statute
area
uh number two uh uh professor amar i
think uh
focused on whether you want to have the
legislative leaders and a possible
uh interruption if you're changing
parties in in midstream
uh and that might call for a different
line of succession perhaps a cabinet
line of succession
similar to what we had in 1886 and there
are proposals to deal with issues such
as a dual disability at the same time
with the president vice president
to make it to clarify uh who judges that
good um a quick quick question um does
the president have the power to
self-pardon
do we think the president can
self-pardon is that a
it's the first principle the
constitution is law law presupposes the
rule of law
and the rule of law for two thousand
years going back to the romans
um and through blackstone is that no one
can be a judge in his own case numa udex
a deep deep fundamental principle of law
and justice
so i think that the very concept of
pardoning yourself is ashonda
okay thank you so i have a a final
question just a wrap-up question i
like to ask in these panels um first of
all if there's any any
uh last comments that any panelists
would like
to make and we'll go in turn um and then
also
is there anything that you would
recommend to our audience
that they that you would recommend that
they read
uh a book or articles either uh
to understand 25th amendment better or
that you've found personally especially
illuminating
regarding the current uh political
situation
without going into what i consider to be
the current political situation i'll let
you interpret that
but anything that you've read recently
or anything that you would recommend
reading
that you found especially enlightening
and illuminating uh
and could we go maybe in reverse order
um david
john and then akil uh yeah
okay
uh david has passed oh thank you uh
uh i i would say uh uh three things
uh uh first book that i reached when i
had a question about section four
uh the fourteenth amendment was uh
professor omar's book
uh the biography of the constitution i
consider it a classic
and uh and it gives it gets me into uh
appreciating the constitution when i
start into that book
as the second uh uh thing that
took me time to do was a a very short
article
and the tribute to uh senator birch spy
where i tried to line up as the
principal author of the amendment
senator bye
i try to line up
what he had to say uh and
with respect to the 25th amendment in a
lot of different contexts it's only 20
pages
and i know uh mrs bai
has distributed the article uh to
friends she has in washington
because uh uh he played such a major
role
and he's alive right now and uh
appreciating his words strike me as
very appropriate and i always look at
the constitution of the united states so
you can't you can't read it often enough
you'll forget what you learned the first
time you don't read it again
perfect okay thank you um akil um
such an honor to be with everyone i'm
going to begin in an awkward and
self-serving way but starting about a
week from now soon as
we have the inauguration and i can
exhale um
i'm launching a a website with my friend
yale class of 78 andy lipka
um it's called the klmar.com and it has
all sorts of readings in it
and we also have a podcast a weekly
podcast
um america's constitution um we've
already lined up
great guests including john fear who's
agreed to come and talk to us
about the 25th amendment i'm going to
actually just
assert right now that that david and
alan at some point will agree to come on
bob woodward
has already agreed to come on we're
going to have really interesting
constitutional conversations so this
a podcast then you'll be able to click
on it from the this website akilamar.com
so that's the awkward thing
um um but truthfully if you're
interested in the 25th amendment other
than reading the amendment itself
this is the book the 25th amendment by
john
barrett his follow-up his other book
from failing
hands is a really interesting account of
every presidential um a death and near
death and disability um
it's fascinating reading and
i have it my office not here for this
narrow purpose
right in our current moment david mayhew
has written so many amazing things
but for this moment where we are
my own favorite might be a recent book
very slender
really filled with all sorts of
interesting data that he wrote on
partisan balance we are in the middle
possibly of
some really interesting possible
realignments
um uh uh huge perhaps a real
breakup of the republican party in
certain ways and david's book on
partisan balance would be
very high on my list of things to read
terrific um david do you have any final
comments you'd like to make before we
conclude
so i'm just so i've learned a lot from
this channel
terrific thank you so much okay well
that concludes our
event for tonight um thank you all for
attending
uh thank you again to uh pam
uh green pamela monica tori bilsky and
lamar pierre
for all of their work uh setting up this
event uh
if you're interested in the recording of
this event it will be posted
at the isps website uh in addition
um we are as i said going to have a lot
of future panel discussions and i hope
i hope you'll uh you'll find it
worthwhile to uh
to attend those as well um with that
thanks again for your attendance
and good evening bye